So far, we've only proven that
one language is unrecognizable.
One technique for
finding more is a mapping reduction,
where we turn an instance of one
problem into an instance of another.
Formally, we say that a language A is
mapping reducible to a language B,
if there's a computable function F.
Where for every string w, w is in A,
if and only if, f(w) is in B.
We write this relation between languages
using the less than or equal to sign.
With a little m on the side to indicate
that we're referring to mapping
reducibility.
It helps to keep in your
mind a picture like this.
Here we have the language A,
a subset of sigma star.
And here we have the language B,
also a subset of sigma star.
In order for the computable
function f to be a reduction,
it has to map each string
in A to some string in B.
And each string not in
A to some string not in B.
The mapping doesn't have
to be one-to-one or onto,
it just has to have this key property.